Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr and it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday, April 23rd, 2018 what's going on?
How are you?
How's it going?
I'm actually recording
this on fucking Wednesday.
April 25th case.
You're listening to this in the future
and you wanted to know what was going on
with me as far as my health goes. Now
notice I said, as far as my health goes,
instead of healthwise,
I learned in vocab improvement
back in high school.
There's no such thing as the
wiseguys healthwise weather wise.
You know, that's why I can never
listen to come fly with me. Why the,
why is it such a lovely day?
A frank, I know you connected,
but that's improper grammar.
All right?
I'm not attacking you or your heritage
or the fact that you from New Jersey or
right. You overly sensitive. So and so,
um, I'm just saying that that's, you know,
I don't know who wrote that song.
Okay.
So why don't you Scooby doo the.dot,
dot. Abou over to a fucking dictionary.
And you, you find me
weather-wise, Francis. Um,
am I really trashing a dead fucking
Frank Sinatra? Sorry, I'm, I'm not, I'm,
I'm almost lied and tried to tell you
I'm on cold medication when I don't take
cold medication.
Cold medication is for
fucking millennials.
All right. And even if you're older and
you take it, you're a millennial at heart,
he can't deal with the fact that you
got yourself sick. You need to lay down,
get eight hours and let your body
fucking go through it. All right?
The reason why your nose is running
this cause is trying to get the virus. I
just let it APP. He's fucking
assholes. I swear to God, man.
The amount of people that gave me advice,
you know,
there's no cure for the common cold, but
everybody thinks they have one. You know,
I'd say I'd go try some zinc shot a
whiskey tube I manage manager told me,
he goes, vitamin D, everybody
thinks it's safe. Vitamin D,
unbelievable. Well, the
greatest managers in the world,
and he also knows the cure for
a cold. I mean, who knew that?
Which is fucking with you, Dave. Um,
let's get that higher on
the way. Um, Jesus Christ,
this is just a cold that won't quit.
This is the cold that's letting me
know that mother nature is regrouping.
You know,
right now we're squeezing her all right.
Like the way Andre,
the giant was squeezed in fucking Hulk
Hogan in that documentary and they lift
in Mother Nature's arm
and then dropping it down.
They lifted up to dropping it down like,
oh my God, the bad guys are gonna win.
And at one point or I'm just gonna stay
there and she's going to start shaking a
fucking blonde hair.
I was always my favorite part when,
how could start coming back and he'd
give him that one big head and then he'd
walk around the ring looking up in the
looking up at the rafters to shake his
head. Uh, that was the best. I watched
that documentary like three times.
And when, uh, when, um, I watched that,
that part of the fight with NEA,
we were both laughing our asses
off in a great way, like day,
just some of the greatest fucking
performers of all time and professional
wrestlers.
You know,
when I was growing up right through
the rock and all of those guys,
like their ability, stone cold, all
of them, their ability to work a crowd
is just, it's second to none. You know,
I got a buddy of mine's
still going like, dude. Yeah,
but isn't it like a fake fight? You
know it, but isn't it like a fake fight?
It's just like I,
how fucking dumb are you?
It's like, yes, it's entertainment.
They think they fucking set at like
30 years ago and some guy cried.
All right.
And the greatest thing they ever did was
say that it was all arranged and all of
that shit for the most part.
So then they could actually talk about
how fucking heart they got when they
actually would do in these fake fights.
I had to tell Burnsy though, likeZ ,
if you knew,
okay,
we had a fake fight and I said I was
going to pick you up and throw you across
the room and you're going to
land on your back, you know,
that would still hurt even though,
you know,
we arranged that I was going to happen.
Right. Physics is still in play there. No,
sorry,
I'm a little hot here with this fucking
Mike's and I was having a problem with
my recorder here. Oh God.
Um, so believe it or not,
I'm actually on the other side of this
thing. I completely lost my voice by,
uh, by Sunday. And um,
so I started gargling with a little bit
of a apple cider vinegar and some salt
in there. That kind of cleared
me up a little bit. Um,
I'll do that shit,
but I'm not going down to the
fucking drug store even though I did.
And I bought all this shit and I just
looked at the ingredients. I'm like,
I'm not putting this in my fucking body.
So basically what?
I kicked the shit out of my fucking liver.
So this medicine can fool my fucking
knows that I don't have a cold.
I apologize to file stuff Ian.
But I gotta do this cause I'm going to
be fucking backed up on podcast cause I
got the Thursday one tomorrow.
I'm liking that.
I love Lucy sketch where they got the
chocolates coming down except it's
podcasting and he cries, I don't
have time for this shit. Um,
guess what the fuck I watched yesterday
on the plane coming back actually went
up to Boston and I visited
my family big east and I'm
on a two,
by the way,
the fucking anger that is
still in Massachusetts.
It's not really what the younger kids,
which kind of makes me happy
and a little bit sad. You know,
some point you do have
to let go of the anger,
but I hope I help all the characters
are still, you know, around.
But I was driving through my,
uh,
my old neighborhood and I was this cop
to erect and traffic and a little fucking
three way stop. He tells this guy
to stop and evidently he didn't.
And the cop starts flipping
out and I'm like, fucking two,
three cars down the line. So I,
I can't hear what the guy say,
but he is fucking flailing his
arms like Earl weaver, right.
He manages the Orioles about
fucking 40 years ago. Sorry. Um,
and I'm laughing my balls off. How
fucking angry is it? The Sky. Right.
And then when he gets the guy to stop
and then the other key waves us to start
going,
like that's not enough for him.
He walks up to the guy's car
and starts screaming at him.
So I'm thinking maybe this is some young
punk with his radio turned up and he's
not listened to the cop. I show up. It's
like some old dude with like white hair,
this fucking eight foot
cop screaming at him.
Uh, I don't know how
you do it. I would not,
I would not have handled that.
Well if he came up to my window,
there's no way I would've been like relax.
And then I would have been, you know,
in cuffs,
cause she can't tell a guy who's flipping
out and screaming at you to fucking
relax.
I need to learn my rights for those
moments because I am a control freak and I
forget that.
I don't know how to fight in those moments
and I just immediately go to go fuck
yourself. And then, and
then the ramification comes
that I am not prepared for.
Um,
I actually got angry for
that guy and started,
drove past the cops saying all this shit
to the cop in my car to myself as if I
was that guy talking to that cop of
fucking nuts. Is that or is that normal?
Is that something you do?
I just feel like for me,
yeah.
Ah, Jesus Christ. Um,
I haven't been this sick
since I've been at Dan,
which is fucking brutal to get this
sick when you're a dad because then you
can't hug your kid.
Uh,
which is the worst.
I mean,
that's what you have a kid
for so he can hug up right in.
Lie about what you did when you were
a kid. Right. That's what you do. Wow.
I used to make my bed every day.
I did all my homework.
I was never a problem for my parents.
Um,
anyways, I, uh, I had a fucking amazing
weekend, so I got to work for the Ryman.
Once again. That's the third time I've
been there. I did Vince Vaughn's, uh,
Nashville Comedy Festival in
2014 than I did it again in 2016.
I take my life specialty
or walk your way out.
And then I got to do a one show Friday,
one show Saturday,
and they brought me a drum
kit and shit to play on.
And I was so sick I couldn't
play. It felt bad. And, um,
I had a splitting fucking,
but the shows were really
fun and I actually a,
I always hit that Jack's
barbecue next door and then,
uh, I went to the Woolworth,
they're going to Woolworths sales
like, oh, with a fucking lunch counter.
Like where they had like back
in the day during segregation,
whether they just like only white people
can sit here and get a grilled cheese
sale,
which God made everybody in his image.
Buddy made us culture to his image and
he loves his just a little bit better
because of that.
We get to see that this shiny
counter that RST you on wide wide,
wide fucking guy gotta go around back.
Uh,
so I sat down, I got a
fucking cheeseburger. They're,
you know, taking pictures.
Just I, I went into Woolworth's like
a white person going, oh my God,
I remember these things.
You know,
he used to be able to buy fucking his
shirt and then get a cheeseburger.
So I walked in not realizing
the historical, um,
magnitude of what I was walking
into. I was just walking, okay guys,
just sell shirts here now buddy.
We doubt we don't have to.
And I walked right up
to the fucking count.
I was taking pictures and shit and
everybody thought I was like some fucking
historian and I wasn't,
I was as excited that had the same
emotional historical context to me is if I
walked into a Jordan Marsh,
did they have Jordan Marsh has anymore?
Do you remember all those? Uh,
all those defunct superstores
it's funny,
they were evil when they came out cause
they put out the mom and pop businesses
and then eventually when you watch them
get eaten yellow, you, he ended up, uh,
feeling bad for them.
Okay.
Places like mammoth mark,
you remember mammoth mart and a big woolly
mammoth child world got destroyed by
fucking toys r us leach mayor.
They lost out to the fucking best buys.
Radio Shack is still a few of them
left over. You know what I mean?
They're like fucking old Nazis is still,
a couple of them are running around
scurrying around South America.
You know what I mean? Trying to get a
fucking tant fit in with the regulars.
Right.
Um Hm.
Well some of the other ones
that they used to have,
I can't even remember
anyone so long goes filings,
Jordan Marsh that Macy's just came a log,
just fucked him all up.
Just fucked him all up.
Bloomingdale's beat the
fuck out of everybody.
And then you had all those like stores
she just heard about. But you know,
like Saks fifth avenue
when I was a little kid, I,
they might've been one in Boston,
but I think if you wanted to go to Saks
fifth avenue, had to go to fifth avenue
in New York City and nobody
really fucking knew all of the,
all of that, all of that
designer shit that, um,
all the kids were nowadays like,
and I was like mobile, Alabama.
They had like a fucking a Louis Vuitton
store. They never used to have that shit.
Okay.
Do you know what I mean?
They only had three series of the BMW,
the three, the five and the seven
though. They also had the six.
If you couldn't afford one of those,
go fuck yourself.
They didn't make it fucking SUV. I
didn't think. I don't think they did.
They didn't have a one series, a
to series of four series, you know,
just fucking doing anything they can.
That's,
I couldn't Miss Mercedes Benz
drop their Co. Not that quality,
but they dropped it all the way
down where you could buy the, uh,
was it the one 90? He, the
baby Benz, they used to call it
a sudden you drive around in Mercedes
Benz that cost the same amount of money as
a Monte Carlo,
right?
And you were this Monte Carlo
fucking t top pot dealer Douche.
You know who would it looked
right in his Oldsmobile cutlass.
But instead you'd ride around this one
90 he like, you're fucking sophisticated.
Everybody saw right through
your, you know, second he
got out of the fucking car,
right though your personal belongings
fall on the fucking ground. You know,
some scale to weigh your product.
I know what I'm talking about.
But when I was a kid,
all the cool older guys to guys who
like 25 which to me was a man yet a
mustache.
You had your own place.
It chick was living with you and you can
fuck her whenever you wanted. You know,
my id is a 14 year old to
eat Liz with her daycare.
He can fuck her whenever he wants to.
Not Realizing,
not realizing like the fucking
that he was probably looking at me,
envious of me.
Go and look at that fucking orange headed,
hairless faced fucking loser over there.
He's got it all ahead of does
it have any credit card bills?
It doesn't have some broad living with
a bitch moaning and complaining about
where he leaves his fucking neon
green fucking sunglasses anyways.
But when I was looking at him,
they were the coolest people ever.
And then there was,
there was the Buick Regal,
no Monte Carlo in the Oldsmobile cutlass
and they were the these two door coops.
And if you've got the fucking
t top, you know, I love it.
I love the guy that went
down to the fucking art,
whatever the whatever auto parts store
that the auto zone's eight all up.
If you go down there.
And I remember people would get their,
uh, they put curb finders on them,
they'd cut tee tops at them.
They get the glass tinted,
the fucking headlights tinted,
all these cheesy shit.
They'd get accustomed license
plate on the front said like Mikey,
you know,
you are the fucking mad if you
actually get a CD player and Emma,
that was a big thing. Like you
gotta like it was an external thing.
I remember this guy I knew he had
a fucking Volkswagen show, Rocco,
which I swear to God, that
was the name of the car. Um,
and he had this fucking
CD player and it was like,
it was like an external hard drives.
Like you had to plug this cord in that
bed plugged into the CD that was mounted
on the arm rest between
the two bucket seats.
And if you even hiccuped in the car,
the CD skipped,
but it was still fucking insane.
Then of course she had to have your
radar detector for the fucking state he
stowed. And all of that is God. You
know it back debt. If you've got a cold,
you put a little Vick's vapor rub on
your fucking chest and that was it.
No wonder they got
Jesus Christ and if could fucking,
they can hold off the HIV virus.
Now you'd think that they could fucking,
you know,
do something about the cold.
But you always pay a price is always a
price to pay. You know, he's always pet,
you know, he's the battered fucking wife
of your organs is your fucking liver.
Your liver always takes it.
You know what I mean?
You fuck up in other areas and
then you take your medicine, right?
Here's scatterbrain loaded take.
You can't get to sleep.
So you take some Tylenol pm and who
pays for it? Huh? You fucking liver.
MMM.
How many times are you going to have
your liver have to walk around with his
eyes looking down at your fucking
colon, you know, as the other fucking
Oregon's it going. What
happened? I walked into the ribs.
Is he making light of domestic violence?
Yes,
I am. Um, I think that's the
problem with this country.
There needs to be more domestic violence.
We actually live in an era that summer
wouldn't even look at that even remotely
is fucking absurd.
Um,
and in an era where fucking,
I can't say the word anymore,
people, unlike the, uh, the Internet,
we'll just take that clip and
they try to get you in trouble.
You know what I mean? Everybody's rat
and everybody out. Like, you know,
I really looked at that
fucking Conor McGregor thing.
Who was that guy videotaping it for?
And then he fucking puts it up on the
fucking Internet and just get Cisco Guy
and all this fucking trouble. I'm not
saying Conor McGregor was right, but like,
who's this fucking ass? Like if I was
there, I wouldn't videotape that shit.
I would just be like, wow, glad
I wasn't on that bus. Right.
You know?
I mean,
that guy's a reason.
Everybody on that bus who's making fucking
a zillion dollars anyways, isn't he?
I can't every once in a while throw a
fucking two wheeler at a god by me. Chip,
you're the fucking champ,
you know?
Okay.
We'll get a little bit of leeway.
All it takes is one fucking touche with
his flip phone and all of a sudden he's
down there talking to the,
okay,
uh, I don't know if talking about,
guess what today is everybody? Oh,
it's gained seven for the Boston Bruins.
Um,
everybody's freaking out and
all this shit. I'm like, God,
we have three games to one.
It gives a fuck.
How are we going to do is win tonight?
Well, you gotta do is win tonight.
No one fucking remembers so
many series that are three,
two, one, go to game seven.
It happens all the fucking time.
MMM.
I will say though,
as a Bruins fan,
if I see and have to listen
to one more commentator,
tell me that it was a stretch pass.
MMM.
You know, and Jesus Christ said,
Anderson has played so great for Toronto.
I don't know why he does all that, flop
it around you literally skate by the guy.
Wind knocks him off his fucking feet.
Just shameless, shameless. But, um,
I liked the fucking maple leafs,
you know what I mean?
Despite their timidly cocky fans on
Twitter who said absolutely nothing,
and now all of a sudden, you know, they
like mere cats, you know what I mean?
With a fucking Cobra comes around and they
all sit there lunging at you and shit,
talking all this shit as a backup.
But they're not really going to fight.
They're trying to appear bigger than
they are. Um, I got no beef with Toronto.
You guys went tonight. Congratulations.
I can get past it. I don't give a fuck.
Right. Um, I know that we're a
team of the future and so you guys,
this would probably be the beginning
of a great rivalry. That's who we need.
God knows because the Canadians
are in the fucking shit or
mmm.
I have this fucking guy that like,
I came from her fuck,
I met him soon,
like a Gig a long time ago and he drove
us there and somebody got my phone
number, this fucking cunt.
Every year during the playoffs.
[inaudible] the bruise do so good.
Good. One of those fucking do shit.
So I finally,
I just finally blocked his number.
[inaudible] I don't get
this. Gets like, I get it.
You fucking drove me to a couple of gigs.
I get to listen to your fucking horse
shit. Every time we're doing bad,
there's so many fucking county
sports fans like that. Um,
and after almost 20 years
of voting a cell phone,
I finally learned how to block people.
I love it.
It's fucking love it.
It's just like ill if somebody I used
to work with to this business fucking,
I don't know what the fuck his deal was,
he fucking started calling
me and emailing me. Yeah.
Block over.
You know what I mean?
It's like you get to assassinate somebody
without having to kill him and deal
with the guilt,
you know.
Okay.
I wonder if in the future when we're all
just being watched by robots and every
last thing you do is videotaped.
Um,
so you can't do anything wrong.
I wonder if they'll have to switch
the commandments just so they can get
somebody in trouble because
nobody can do anything anymore.
So rather than thou shall not kill
the fifth commandment, we'll be,
thou shall not block
somebody on your cell phone.
You shall not assassinate them digitally.
I'm sorry,
did I just,
did I just float out a perfect
premise for the next blade runner?
Um, no I didn't. I did that. However,
there was that movie that came out where
people had to take a test and if you
know, when the world was
overpopulated, those fucking cuts,
where the hell did you get that idea? It,
God bless him. But you know what I mean?
How about a tip of the cap?
Um,
anyways, side people have
just had a fucking, all right,
I've just had a headache for so physical.
I did buy some bare aspirin. I did that.
Uh, Celtics. Everybody
about those Boston Celtics.
How about the hot or the Boston Celtics?
And how about those
fucking Milwaukee Bucks?
This is the best state Ben since backward.
Like Sidney Moncrief,
you know that they got that white dude
from fucking the Seattle Sonics with that
fuck was his name
Jack Sick?
Um, but I have to be honest with you,
dude, the basketball is so fucking awful.
Then I'm watching,
they're I even playing hoop.
It looks like a fucking pickup game and,
and an unbelievably high level.
How many fucking times can you throw
up a three with nobody underneath
is it, let me, I don't understand
that new little semicircle there.
I gotta look read up on it in the paint.
Is it illegal if you don't have the ball
as an offensive player to get under the
fucking rib?
Was the last time you saw a center post
up and put his hand in the air and do a
couple up and under. She got a little
Kevin Mchale Action Little Sky Hook.
It's all fucking God.
You just run down the court a little
pass and then the guy just takes a three
point.
I didn't go ahead
or somebody does so and one shit to
try to get around. A guy dropped foul.
It's fucking,
it's horrible.
I think a lot of the
entire second quarter,
I don't think I saw one pick and roll.
You know,
there's a reason that they did that for
fucking close to 80 years. It works.
I don't know why everybody's trying
to do this globe trotter shit.
[inaudible] uh, having said that, I
love where we're going in the future.
I just don't like the future of the game.
I guess people got too big.
Is that what it was?
Um,
I missed the bang and down
low in the paint, you know?
Yeah.
And then fucking old school yard play
where the guy's leaning against you leave
it and you stepped out behind him. Like
he pulled his chair out, he falls down,
then they'd stand up and
get in each other's grills
there the little fucking ref
came up to the Dick's was trying to
push them apart. I miss all of that.
I missed it man. I miss
the way you smell. Um,
I actually got to be honest with
you, I shut the game off. Okay.
Cause I was so fuck I, cause I fucking
hate NBA hoop. I just hate basketball.
I just hate how no lead is safe.
It's like you're up by 40,
you go with the kitchen and then you
make a sandwich and it's like the other
team on a 38 to
follow the three pointer.
This could tie it up. It's
just like, can there ever be,
can you ever just have an easy win?
Um,
I just felt myself getting ready to throw
something at the fucking TV and I got
a kid now so I can't,
so I just shut it off and I was just,
then I just watched the score throughout
the fourth quarter and they want it.
I was like good. Uh, a more of
a hockey guy. Obviously, um,
and having said that, I, you
know, of course I have to,
I've got to edit some shift for
emphasis of family tonight. Um,
but I'll get to watch most of the game.
It's only a game seven,
you know, um, I'm very excited for this.
You gotta love of games of it.
Even if your team was up to your one
who gives a fuck gotta love a game.
Seven and a, and here's the
deal is if we lose to Toronto,
that's my team for the rest of the
playoffs because they haven't won since 67
and uh,
I think it's high time that they get and
it'd be cool to see Winnepeg get their
first one. So those are my
two teams. Those are my onesy.
Twosy alright. Um, so there you go.
There's your fucking Bruins
as your NBA and Nhl Hay fever.
Fucking talk for the God damn week.
Oh,
you know what else I forgot to fucking
mentioned? I started to mention it. Well,
maybe I'll mention it after I,
I do a little law.
I got one read for this week. All right.
Boto Dude, do me on days me undies.
Get in the fucking paint. Do,
do dooby on days beyond ease.
Throw it down to is tanked.
Sped around and fucking dunk it.
Stop throwing up threes if you please.
It's fucking boring.
I feel like I'm at the fucking
Ymc a except people can't dunk.
You've heard me talk about me undies
and you know that I'm a big believer
in their product.
They just sent me another bag onto where
these guys got to stop. It's just like,
I don't have a bladder
problem. Okay, I get it.
You guys make a lot of underwear.
I have some and I like it.
You don't need to send me
some every fucking month.
Treat me like you fucking
underwear whore on the side. Uh,
there perfect balance of comfortable fit.
Every month they have new and exciting
prince and they arrive at your door and
have fun. Bag me undies. Uh, uses
Lenzing micro modal. Modal in their
underwear is sustainably sourced.
Naturally soft fiber that starts with
beechwood trees and ends with the most
imagined amazing fabric
you've ever experienced.
I don't know why that is in the
fucking copy. At least in my copy.
My listeners are not smart.
I'm not smart.
When you start saying that your
underwear is made out of trees,
we start thinking about getting split
us in our under carriage, you know?
Yeah.
Joe Era about fucking Fitzy can't
have kids be is fucking underwear.
It was being out of beechwood trees.
A fucking took them off too fast.
He stabbed both his balls. He's got
nobody. He's got no more Chez left. Well,
it's because it ran down his leg.
Chad, you listen to the fucking story.
The results have been downright
dreamy beyond these adventurers.
Prints and designs are all limited
editions. Yeah. It just, I,
I wouldn't even take them out of the
rap. You know, who knows somebody,
somebody might want to collect them.
Like action figures at new patterns are
released every few weeks on a rolling
basis.
100% satisfaction guarantee.
Okay.
Uh,
Kara Tepe me on these guarantees.
You will love their undies or your money
back if he didn't know what a guarantee
was. Me undies has a great offer for
my listeners. Whatever the fuck else.
They gave us two for any first time
purchasers. When you purchase any on,
did you get 20% off at
a fed free shipping?
We on these is so sure
you'll love their underwear.
They offer 100% satisfaction guaranteed.
You already fucking said this.
If you don't love the first pair,
you get a full refund.
That's a no brainer to
get 20% off of pair.
The most comfortable undies you'll ever
put on to get you 20% off your first
pair of free shipping would
upset satisfactory care
Tigo to be on these.com/bar.
That's me. [inaudible] dot
com slash Berg. All right,
so I've tasted twice.
Let me see.
Liverpool football.
Yeah,
she schedule.
What do they play next?
I was on the plane and I actually watch
liberal Liverpool for fucking robot.
Okay.
Yeah,
and it was a shock. It was a
blowout. It was an awesome game.
Liverpool went up five to fucking nothing.
Yeah,
Saturday 4:30 AM
I don't I? I just, I just don't
fucking get how this shit works.
They're playing robot.
Isn't that like Rome?
Yeah,
that's the Champions League.
Semifinal
leg two of two.
Yeah.
Aggregate two to five.
Yeah. They won five to two.
So they get to play again on May 2nd.
Is that because they scored five
goals and from promise score to,
what is the coincidence that I just
don't understand it because they were up
five to nothing and then
all of a sudden Rome,
Roman scored a goal and then they scored
another one on a penalty kick and then
they was saying in the announcers are
going nuts. I'm like, what day is it?
Fucking two minutes left.
Why?
They flipping out like they're
going to lose this case.
I think there were in some
sort of tournament that
happens at the same time that
the premiership is being played.
Right.
It's weird.
Like that's the Champions League and
I think Liverpool Chelsea, that's
the Premiere Premiere League.
Right? They do it at the same,
somebody for the love of God.
Somebody over there in Great Britain
somewhere around the fucking world
explained to me what's going on.
Cause I actually really enjoyed, um,
the fucking game to this guy. Holy Shit.
This Egyptian dude who kind of look,
he looks like an Egyptian Judd Apatow.
Most Salah,
this fucking guy put on a goddamn clinic.
First of all,
he used to play for Roma. So he scores
a goal. Then he does his big dramatic,
I'm not going to celebrate,
you know,
which was more annoying that if he just
celebrated because said he scored again.
The first one was like a fight. It
was like a lot of it's like hockey.
What fucking top shelf
corner on the far side,
I believe with his left foot.
And then a few minutes later whenever
he comes back down again and he just in
that one, that was the first one was a
fucking blast and the next one is nice,
soft touch right up and over
the fucking guy. The goalkeeper,
I believe for a second goal.
Once again, he starts praying,
getting on his knees and fucking kiss
in the ground and doing all this shit.
Like he's not going to have a
threesome after the fucking game.
You know what I mean? Like he's going to
go fucking rescue a cat out of a tree.
So I do take your junk out and shake
it and the other teams face, you know,
you want to. And then he
set up, he had two assists,
whatever they call the helpers,
uh, two fucking crumpets.
I don't know what the fuck they call you.
Guy had like four points.
If he was playing hockey, two goals,
two assists. It was incredible.
Then there was this other poor best,
and I think he finally scored a goal.
He had a breakaway fuck that up
that he was in when in hockey,
what would be called the slot.
And he just fucking, ms kicked it,
blasted over the fucking net.
I think he spent more time on his
fucking Mohawk than he did on his fucking
learning, on a shoot the ball
into the Goddamn net. But,
uh, there was seven goals.
It was like the kind of fucking soccer
game that a yank could enjoy. But, uh,
I was stuck on a plane and we had
a ridiculous headwind. I was like,
I'm going to sit here and
watch this fucking thing. And
I totally got into it. Uh,
by the way, Liverpool's
fucking, uh, coach,
his dentists should be fucking disbarred.
He should have his license
fucking revoked. You know,
I'm sure it was the coach's idea,
but if you got to fucking go tan and you
don't get your fake teeth whitened to
that level,
Jesus Christ,
he looked like the plant in little shop
of horrors except he had glasses on.
MMM.
So anyways, I was really into
it, so I guess they're going to,
why is it so much time between games
though? Oh No. The next one is April 28th.
That's it. I'm going to watch. Fuck
it. I'm going support Liverpool.
I liked the Beatles. Who gives a fuck,
right? Like I got time for this shit.
Uh, there's no way to watch it and not
all of a sudden what I have a fucking beer
though, I will tell you that, you
know, and I've been fucking Billy,
no fund Billy, no vice other
than four hits a weed one night,
which I immediately regretted.
Cause all it does is make me sleepy and
I'm trying to become one with the world.
I don't get munchies. I just fall asleep
like a cat on a fucking window sill.
I don't give a fuck where I am.
I'm going to sleep. Yep. Um,
anyways,
let's get over with the questions here.
I still haven't watched that moto GP.
I know that mock mock has wanted a,
when there was a big anticipation
than him in a Valentino Rossi.
We're going to be fucking donkey kicking
each other about fucking 200 kilometers.
Uh, but he just fucking blew by
everybody by the second turn. Um,
I don't know. I got to watch it though.
I fucking love that sport though. Okay.
Emails for the week. I might have to
do a little short, uh, podcast here.
Everybody in the fucking voices bucket
the shit out of me. All right, Belgium.
Hey Bill,
would you consider to come back to
Belgium in 2019 please keep us posted.
Uh, absolutely I would. I was only
there for like 24 hours and I loved it.
I was in Antwerp, I believe. Excuse me.
[inaudible]
yeah, gross. Disgusting.
Sorry. It has to be done.
It has to be done.
You're gonna blow it out.
I should have do a kid show sketch
about having a cold, you know,
you just have some up at
that's always fucking sick.
And then the kids can't fucking sale
touched the thing cause it's sick.
And then you make them come up
and act all sad cause it's lonely.
And then when the kids come over
because they feel bad for it,
he chastised the hell out of him for
giving it to the weak emotion of love.
And you have your set him up for the
real world. Uh, fish start a pack.
You know what? I downloaded one of their
cities. Their harmonies are amazing. Uh,
the music,
it doesn't quite grab me.
They're incredible fucking musician,
but they just stayed. There's a,
I dunno, do something. I will
keep listening. All right,
you're talking about fucking bed that's
sold out Madison Square Garden like 18
nights in a row or something. So
it's, it's gotta be me on some level.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
I look at fish, the way I look at
Beyonce, like it's gotta be me, right?
I have to be the person. That's when
somebody fills up the fucking Rose Ball.
You know what I mean?
The second they say they're going
to be there and you're like, yeah,
I don't get it. Then at some
point it's you. It is you, right?
I don't know.
Dare is bright breathes breaths.
I would always sit when I appreciate,
while I appreciated the last fish suggests
fish suggested of starting with rift.
It's a very specific album.
Pretty ballsy of that guy
who started with rift.
It's as if he wants to
make it hard on you. Okay.
I like this guy. I liked the other
guy too. They thought I was smart.
I like this guy because he
knows I'm stupid. All right.
Yeah. Make it easy, man.
Give me the answers you should download.
Hoist.
It's funny you say that and as
the last guy suggested alive,
one that'll give you something fun
to work with. Again, I love rifts,
but I also want you to have a fair shot.
Also,
story of ghost is funky and
Billy Billy breaths is fun too.
Who Was it? Billy breathes.
I'm so dumb,
and not to sound cliche,
but have you seen dead and company yet?
It's a really fun show and
definitely worth checking out, man.
Yeah,
those hippy shows,
there's just such a vibe of,
of uh,
insincerity at them that I can't handle
from the crowd where everybody's just
trying to like,
I don't know.
You don't like when you see a mom and
she's talking to a kid in public and
talking really loudly, some cute
conversation in looking at you smiling.
It's like, will you shut the fuck up
when you bring the volume down? I get it.
Kids are cute. It's not my kid. You know,
I don't care that the kid
just counted the five.
No, not busy. You have to sit there.
You need to put these young here for
Duquesne and they look at you and smile is
they do the play by play of
the kid putting a fucking
marshmallow in its mouth.
I feel like when you go to one of those
hippie things, people are doing that,
but they're kind of doing it, you know,
to show like how everybody's, you know,
this is like how society should be man.
Um,
ah, in the fucking the body
odor. I don't mean like,
I mean the Cologne that they wear,
whatever the fuck it is. Just the, uh,
the, the, the fucking Douche Gumbo.
That's what I can't answer when I'm there.
It's always fucking heart, you know?
And everybody's wearing a sun dress.
It's just, I don't know. I'm
too much of a curmudgeon. Um,
why I think we bombed Syria. Oh,
code for you. Help me out here.
All bill ball bag.
Uh,
I believe we blew their chemical weapon
plants up because they gassed little
kids.
Okay.
Just a guess of what I read.
I think you overly simplified and
I think some kids also died. Um,
but if we're going to
start doing that body,
if we're going to start bombing people
because they gas people are bond people
and killed little kids. Ah, everybody
who does that is a piece of shit.
I don't know how well
we come out in the wash,
their pal chested casts from what I've
read. But you're not allowed to say that.
Cause if you do that means you're an isis.
You're not allowed to criticize anything.
It'd be like,
what the fuck are we doing? Uh, but
I do understand your fear of debt.
Love the cast in your work as
unimportant as it may seem.
We couldn't live without laughing piece.
Okay man,
you got your sun dress
on there. Um, yeah. Okay.
I understand that Syria, okay. What they
did was horrifically wrong, but you know,
should we have a lot more of our ducks
in a row before we start policing the
fucking world is all I'm saying.
You know what I mean?
If we're gonna fucking bomb those
guys cause they guess a little kids,
that sounds good, but
you know, at what point,
where are they going to fucking shoot
some missiles at the people who poisoned
our food supply,
the food supply,
that net we're now trying to sell
around the world and people like you not
bringing that shit in our country. Do
you know this? Say that about our food,
like France and India.
France is like, all right,
but you're going to have to say what's
in it. And we're like, no, we're not.
We are dish. No Way. We're going to say
what's in our food. How fucked up is that?
And I got to try to navigate those
waters with my kid, you know,
and there's no explanation to
it. There's no, well, listen man,
if you want to somehow make 300
people not starved to death,
you got to cut some corners,
then I understand it. But
there's, there's nothing,
they're not saying anything. They're
like, shut the fuck up in, uh, any,
um, you know, I dunno,
the key in this world to make it is
you've got to make so much money.
You can donate the politicians' campaigns
and then they just fucking leave you
alone.
And you can do whatever you want.
Like poisoned the food supply of a
country, which if I'm not mistaken,
is a terrorist act.
When you then become an
evildoer, uh, dude, I'm fat.
This is all shit. You're not allowed to.
If you can say it about anybody else.
But if you actually fucking
Kev, constructive criticism
about your own team,
you're immediately a conspiracy theorists
or you're a socialist. You know,
I don't understand.
I don't know when the fuck that happened,
but it's brilliant PR. So evidently
I'm a communist right now. Oh, Billy.
He's got a red beard.
I mean,
it's all right there probably jerks
off to Stalin's fucking head shot every
morning. Now dairy want healthy food
for everyone in this country. Uh,
hey bill, no fun. A Billy, no fund.
Love the podcasts. I'm a fat guy.
Totally agreeing with you.
Fat people blame everyone around them.
But I'm one that knows that I shouldn't
be shoving cheeseburgers down my gullet.
Yeah,
dude,
that's the power fucking
choice right there.
If you stopped blaming everybody
else and all this other shit outside,
he has to change is you keep fucking
show in this shit. Like granted,
I don't have a psychology degree or
even know anything about nutrition as I
trashed what's in our food
supply. Um, you know, you know,
Kenny Rogers was the gambler of
the hypocrite. Uh, anyone. Anyway,
my question is do you think it's worse
to know that you are ruining your life
and eating like a fat fuck or pretending
like it's a thyroid problem or some
excuse. Anyways, please
come to the bay area.
I am up doing a whole weekend shows in
May up in San Francisco or reno cause I
miss you on the last one. Uh, all right.
Do you think it's worse to know that
you're ruining your life and eating like a
fat fuck or pretending like
it's a thyroid problem?
I think if you pretend like it's a
thyroid problem is a good way to go.
If your apps,
if you had no power in this situation,
like um,
a lot of the shit that I alluded to,
you know like our food supply and
like I'm powerless against that.
So it's something I will joke about
and then I quickly don't think about it
because I don't know what to do. You know,
you go down to a farmer's market and
those kinds of infiltrated down there too,
when you start asking the fucking hippie
down there, so this is blah blah blah.
Where did this come from?
And they start getting no fucking
shifty themselves and they then all of a
sudden you feel like you're an invasion
of the body snatchers, you know, so, um,
but I think the fact that
you're addressing that,
you're the ones shoving the
cheeseburgers down your gullet. Um,
okay.
I have found that, uh, you
know, the longest time I
didn't think food was a drug.
I totally believe it now.
And Dean del Ray put me on this,
I guess it's a gluten free diet and I'm
on this and I barely have to work out,
you know, and a keynote is
like this fucking amazing.
Like I eat the food that I eat on this
diet afterwards, I don't feel like, ah,
I gotta take a nap. I feel like energized
even though I feel like shit right now.
But, um, I dunno. And I
was taking a Multivitamin,
somebody shit all over that go,
let's designate I love this and up or that
you need to take this. It's just like,
okay. All right. All right. So, uh,
I think it's,
it's
okay.
Well, look, if you're not going to
do anything about being a fat fuck,
it's going to be more painful.
If you're just going to continue to be
a fat fuck or not do anything about it,
then I would lie. That's your thyroid
problem. You know what I mean?
MMM.
You know, that's like if you put
out something artistic and uh,
it doesn't do well and then you blame
okay.
The left or the right
or some shit like that.
Like I've seen with some movies and
other shit. You can do that if you want.
It's not going to help you.
Next fucking project the project
have you navy training in Australia.
You know Jesus Christ is the last fucking
place I would be in the Goddamn Navy
is Australia.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
What do you have to do to become
a fucking navy seal in Australia?
Do you have to stab a great white
shark to death after they cut? Yay.
Probably make you bleed before you get
in the fucking water. Alright. Hey Bill,
just watched
at voice clip.
I think that voice clip of you on Youtube
about how you watched the two weeks in
health thing. I was in the
Australian navy and it was similar,
but you got shit for not keeping your own.
I don't know what that means.
Preface,
this was before the media cared
about all genders. We had big Bertha,
which on the second day of recruit school,
we were kept up until 2:00 AM and we're
only allowed a breakfast bar the night
before they woke us up by smashing trash
cans in each of our dorms right there.
I'd be out, I'd be, I'd be like,
dude, fuck this. And I'd walk out, uh,
they'd be like, good you two week.
And I'd be like, you're right.
I'm going to a holiday. Yeah. I want
to thank all of you for protecting me.
He may eight hours sleep.
All right.
That we had to run down stairs and
carry the rope called Big Bertha,
which was the equivalent. Oh my
God. Of the old ships anchor lines.
And we ran for about six kilometers,
3.7 miles. What the fuck?
Until we were allowed
to have food after that.
Anyone that couldn't continue,
we were partnered up with and had to
carry them and big Bertha shaming the
people that couldn't continue.
Uh,
I couldn't do that.
I couldn't do that dude where
they up on the rope weeping.
Did they literally get broken
that bad? And we went, well,
when we eventually got back to base,
we were allowed breakfast and then had
to go on with the eight hour drills and
fulfill our duty watches.
Yeah.
Wow. Dude, that is some psychological
breakdown right there. Holy Shit.
The most fucked up
thing about all of this.
Yeah.
Hey, wait dude, did you make it
through all of this? Oh my God.
Do you have your 80 or
difficult it is to be me.
Has your girlfriend ever said that to
you when you're thinking about that big
birthday March? Uh, was this, okay?
This was in m o two o three and
the Australian Defense Force,
our military, God forbid
we seem aggressive. Oh,
you say defense force had instituted
a policy where females could only be
treated or ordered for
so many hours a day.
So handing Avs dash gas helicopter fuel.
So okay,
helicopter fuel was only be performed
by men because it caused impotence in
women but also men.
But females could hold positions on the
yeah, but they can also make a baby.
They know anybody. We'll fuck himself.
Your Dick and your balls are expendable
at that point. That's simple math.
But females could hold positions
on the the Hilo refuel team,
well that doesn't make sense, but when
it came to actually handling fueled,
they get volunteer males to do it after
dealing with shit like being blamed
because my ship couldn't get any new
workers from land because the ship was a
fucking grinder and being in charge of
people when I haven't even been promoted,
I decided to just start drinking so much.
I got kicked off and it
was my best decision ever.
This is like a great movie.
Spent my last year of my contract
at a base in a rich part of Sydney,
Australia surfing in the morning and
banging a few of the new female sailors
that all over 21 he puts in parentheses
that had never been to sea by proudest
moment was when I was awarded the
humanitarian aid metal because I build
hospitals in Sumatra
after the o five tsunami.
I spent days helping and building and
the people of Sumatra with some of the
most thankful and kindest people ever met
who had a fucking great story that is,
Oh my God. Can you imagine if you
quit, like how tired you'd have to be,
how excrutiatingly tires you have
to be to climb up on that rope.
It'd be carried back 3.7 miles.
I just have to go
mentally with every step.
This humiliation is one
step closer to being over.
What do you say when you get off?
Good day, mate. Sorry about that.
I have a fucking,
oh my God.
I can't imagine what people said to you
other way back. Overrated. Underrated.
Alright. Overrated. New
York and Los Angeles.
I've lived in both cities for
over four years each. I love them.
But I've also lived on a creek in
Virginia and a farm in Vermont.
Unless you need to be in one of
those cities, just don't go there.
I that I agree with that wholeheartedly.
You should visit him. Uh, underrated.
Wayne's world.
I never heard you talk about this movie.
He should definitely rewatch this. Next
time you take a hit man. All right,
I'll check it out. I will
definitely check it out. Um,
I had it overrated. Underrated. Okay.
I wait. You know what overrated.
These new fucking elevators
where I got to fucking hit like 20 goddamn
buttons to let the elevator know that
I'm going to floor four so it can fucking
compartmentalize all the people there
when I'm the only fucking person there,
you know,
and I gotta take my key out and
fucking run it over the scanner.
I like the old school ones. We
just got in. You push the button
for fucking 10 years. I was on the
road. That was, that was the way it was.
And I never had that guy from no country
for old men blow out the lock on my
door. You know, it was completely fine.
I don't want to tell him I stayed in a
bed and breakfast in fucking Colorado
with this dude from Germany.
It was so fucking creepy cause he was
walking the halls at night and I was just
sitting there in the hall.
Light would be on,
I was looking at the light and I didn't
have a lock of did I think maybe on a
skeleton cheat and I was just sitting
there. Oh Wow. I just remember my luggage.
I this ugly ass green,
like made out of cloth bag cloth and
plastic at this guy puked on one to
Oh my God, you remember that Jesus
Christ and through a lot of shit people.
All right, let's tell the
chairman would first, so fuck it.
I will tell the pew cord. No,
you got to close with the puke.
I've already told that story
and it's so fucking gross.
I've been puked on twice in my life.
Once on my head,
you know,
everybody in my family had gotten sick
and we had this bathroom was a half a
bathroom with no door.
You were around the corner,
no privacy whatsoever. We lived in a
duplex, squirrels got into the walls.
I had to scare them out and then
my dad would kill him, you know,
was the 70s, eighties, you know,
Shit like that happen. So, um,
there was no place to,
you couldn't,
I couldn't make a Facebook video
and shame my landlord. You know,
where my dad couldn't do that. So he
just stopped. He had to kill the fuckers.
Everybody to proven, I was fucking shaking
it. Try to get this thing to come out.
And my dad was on the other side.
You have this giant fucking butcher
knife or metal bar or something,
I can't remember.
And that was a metal bar.
That's what it was like a
big piece of or something,
a flush that thing out.
And that fucking thing came running
up the broom up the broom handle.
I remember his eyes were wide is shit.
It's tail was straight up in the end.
This little brown Cutie Pie.
Fucking ran up my arm and launched
off on my shoulder. I wait.
And then it ran into the half a bathroom
and it was one way in
and only one way out.
My Dad was in the way and
he fucking brought that led
dig down right on the back
of its fucking deck and just
slowly killed the thing.
And I watched him do it.
MMM.
So anyways,
what time?
We were all fucking sick and I was in
there finishing puking in the bathroom
with no door.
My brother came running in,
I just ran.
And rather than puking in the fucking
sink that was readily available. You know,
we were young,
so it was just like you puke in the
toilet and my head obstructing the toilet
and it was like how low
pressure goes to high pressure.
It takes the most direct route,
which is right through the air foil.
And that's how you get lift when you fly.
He used those same principles,
would puke it into the toilet.
And my head was the airfoil.
Whenever we fucking puked up my head.
And I just freaked out.
And I was punching him as hard as I could
in the stomach as he was continuing to
Puke.
But parents came in,
they were laughing their ass off at bay
and the kitchen sink was there and she
just fucking Doug my head in there and
fucking washed and it was so gross,
so gross.
So then the second time I got puked on,
I was trying to save money and I was
taking a bus from Manhattan to Laguardia
Airport.
We always sent my turmoil.
I take the subway up to Harlem and
then took the bus over the bridge.
And this dude just got up,
look at all great and he
fucking projectile vomited
and he hit the sweet old
lady in front of me on a chest
and it was like the Kennedy
assassination were to spray,
just went back except it didn't go to the
left and went to the right where I was
sitting and it got on my foot,
my sock and my lower pants
and all over my luggage.
And then he just stumbled off the bus
and I was like, you motherfucker. And
I wanted to beat the shit out of him,
but I was broken and I needed the
money and I had to go to my gig.
I just glared at him as all I could
do and then I had to go in there,
got off the bus,
and now people look at me like I'm an
animal because I smelt like fucking puke.
And I
went into the bathroom
like beyond Tourette's,
took the sock off shoe off fucking,
but I only had one pair of footwear
so I threw out the size disgusting.
Had to wash off my fucking
pant leg the best I could.
My sneaker was so good, fucking wet.
I had one sock on, one sock off,
walking into a squishy wet fucking
sneaker and my fucking green cloth bag.
I wiped off all of the Pew,
but it was like stayed and they had like
the little fucking paper towel balls
audit.
It was so fucking gross.
And I then had to get on like a fucking
flight to like Minnesota just sitting
there smelling of stomach acid
and I got off the plane.
Yeah.
I immediately went to a mall and I
bought some sweatpants and the cheapest
fucking sneakers and socks and I
just fucking threw the shit out.
And I bought a bag. But I didn't have
time to do that before, which the boat.
Oh my God. It was a fucking terrible trip.
Oh the fuck. A terrible trip. That was,
um,
but you know,
it's not as bad as what fucking happened
on southwest could've been worse. Yeah.
That poor fucking woman,
Jesus Christ. See,
that's the second time
I've heard of somebody gets
sucked out like that can read
that fucking story that, uh, it fucking
mechanic puts a new windshield on,
get on the plane and uh, uh, lady
used the wrong fucking screws.
They weren't long enough and they
fucking flying like, you know,
they're cruising altitude,
so they got to be going for 500 miles
an hour in the fucking windshield.
Flew off and the captain got sucked out,
but his legs got stuck on the yoke and
he was outside the fucking plane and they
were trying to hold on to them and
the door to the cockpit got blown in.
And the guy couldn't slow down cause
it was on the controls. They sub out,
the stewardess has helped out.
You know when the air pressure
I guess leveled off where they
could move and not get sucked out.
And they were trying to
pull them in and they could,
one of the students could see the guy
outside the window looking at him and is,
he wasn't blinking and she goes, I
think he's dead. We should let him go.
Fortunately they didn't.
They ended up landing.
It turned out the guy was in shock.
Um,
it's fucking nuts.
Just sitting there like catatonic.
He got frostbite in one of his eyes.
It was just,
and this is what kills me is the fucking
maniac was flying again in a couple of
weeks. I think he still
flies. I can't imagine.
You know what the thing is,
is what they really should have in the
back of the plate is you should also have
those shoulder artists
as you should have that
you know when it goes across your
lap and then over your shoulder.
So then if you sit next to the
fucking window, God forbid,
if the fucking thing blows out,
you still find,
but that would be prohibitively expensive.
So I guess what I'm saying is
get the ILC. Alright, everybody,
um, gold Bruins and, uh,
goes Celtics.
Okay.
I had a,
I don't know.
I'm going to go fucking take a hot shower
and try to clear my Goddamn sinuses.
Uh, I want to do another podcast tomorrow.
I'll be all caught up. All right.
Go Fuck Yourself. She can't sit. I'll
check it on your tomorrow. Oh Geez.